[Music]
[Applause]
it's been a crazy week in America let's
find out what happened
see Abrams on Sunday debated Georgia
Republican Governor Brian Kemp and
here's how it went
[Applause]
the massacre wasn't even funny no it
wasn't I hurt my feelings just watching
yeah and I don't even care for that guy
no I don't and I didn't feel sorry for
him
now according to a recent poll 37
percent of Georgia voters think
Republican Senate candidate Herschel
Walker is more trustworthy than Raphael
Warnock while the other 63 percent think
he is Sam eagle
[Music]
I can also fly
um
of course you can present present Biden
on Tuesday visited Florida in an attempt
to drum up votes for the midterms and if
that doesn't work he'll try Plan B
[Music]
okay
the midterm elections will be held on
Tuesday that's right Amber the midterms
will decide who controls the house and
the Senate but who controls that outcome
you do with your vote
[Music]
[Applause]
it's more than just senators and
governors your vote will elect sheriffs
judges and legislators who can affect
the lives of your family and friends
and that's one to grow on
[Music]
yeah
you said it Amber this election is so
crucial that 12 million people have cast
early ballots the most early ballots
cast at this point in any election ever
oh I did not know that now you know and
no one's half the battle
[Music]
now sometimes voters get bumped from
voting rules so double check if you're
registered to vote at vote.org
good milk
yeah yeah that's a great idea Amber
everyone should vote like their lives
depend on it because it does
[Music]
and down ballot voting is just as
important as voting for senators and
governors so check your mailbox for your
State's voters guide and get informed
about who's running yeah
[Music]
yeah
yeah and if you didn't get a voter's
guide in the mail you can find out about
your candidates and their voting records
on nonpartisan websites like ballotpedia
or vote 4-1-1
[Music]
so remember whether you vote by mail
vote early or vote in person this
Tuesday November 8th get out and vote
today
[Applause]
now back to the monologue
a company in Russia is offering the
experience of being buried alive for the
price of fifty seven thousand dollars
while in New York the same experience
cost 275.
according to a recent study white people
who go into cardiac arrest in public are
more likely to receive CPR from
bystanders than black people mainly
because this one guy keeps faking them
hmm I'm coming to Elizabeth sir I'm
coming sir sir
you died
that's taking me
we didn't catch a heart attack you
caught the holy ghost caught the spirit
due to Drought a California City
recently had to buy water on the open
market for over one million dollars and
here's a look at it being delivered
foreign
and finally it was reported this week
that the spin-off to the film a quiet
place May star black panther actress
Lupita Nyong'o because if there's one
thing black people are known for it's
being quiet
and that was a joke Seth can't tell that
was the monologue just like
Halloween
I really liked it no
no you're here at the Amber Ruffin show
we're committed to bringing you all of
the latest news but we're also committed
to bringing you surprise guests that
will blow your freaking mind and we have
one of those here with us tonight I
can't believe this guest is in our
studio right now and that I'm going to
get to hang out with her I'm medically
speaking freaking out please welcome
Jasmine Guy
foreign
[Applause]
thank you for being here I love you
terribly Jasmine I'm so excited that
you're here I've been a fan of yours for
approximately one million years I love
everything you've ever been in and I
pre-loved the things you haven't been in
yet welcome wow that was great thank you
thank you for loving me in the future I
love you in the future I love you in the
past I love you most of all right now no
that's though Jasmine Guy has had an
incredible acting career from
hard-hitting dramas to Broadway musicals
to the iconic sitcom a different world
Ms guy has done it all baby
Jasmine
what
this this has to happen to you
everywhere you freaking go
um Jasmine what is your favorite role
you've ever played oh
I love playing Roxy on Dead Like Me that
was a Showtime series and I love playing
Velma in the Musical Chicago
that answer is correct you have to say
you have an incredible range but just
how incredible well we're gonna find out
right now in a game called a different
read
[Music]
this is how it's gonna work
of dialogue and after each line I'll
call out different acting Styles and
Jasmine will say the line in each of
those Styles thus demonstrating the
mind-blowing depths of her acting range
Jasmine are you ready I am okay your
first line is Oh no I got a stain on my
shirt please say it in the style of
sitcom
Oh no I got a stain on my shirt
and now
drama
oh no
that's stain on my shirt
[Applause]
clock news
and Justin I've got a stain on my shirt
perfection
Jasmine Guy your next line is give me
the fifty dollars you owe me
let's hear it in the style of a Tyler
Perry movie
you better give me my fifty dollars
[Applause]
in the style of a children's show
give me my fifty dollars give me
give me my fifty dollars give me
give me my fifty dollars
hahaha
and let's hear that line in the style of
a Telenovela
please give me my denial
correct okay okay
[Applause]
where's my baby she was right here a
minute ago
let's hear it in the sky of a true crime
documentary
where's my baby
she was right here a minute ago
a stoner comedy
this is my baby
oh just right here
[Applause]
I love a western
words my baby
she was just tritarian a minute ago
[Applause]
there's a hair in my soup let's hear it
as a NPR reporter
waiter there's a hair
in My Soup
[Applause]
I liked it he has an NPR show let's see
that line as a Noir film
waiter
there's a hair
in My Soup
and finally let's hear it in the style
of Broadway
waiter there's a hair
waiter there's a hair in my soup
[Applause]
Jasmine
do you have any party words of advice
for aspiring actors who look up to you
uh work on your craft love what you do
share your love and believe that you can
go
as I believe in you amazing that's
Jasmine Guy this has been a different
read
[Music]
[Applause]